on va faire un petit tour du paf m avec
lui pour commencer on va s'inscrire avec
le monsieur science de m6 c'est ma
caisse qui pour mac
bonjour un brossage des dents efficace
c'est un brossage qui nettoie toutes les
surfaces des dents sans oublier la
bordure gingivale c'est là que la plaque
dentaire est la plus difficile à
éliminer
voilà ce qui arrive quand on ne se
brossent pas correctement les dents
témoignages m'ont volé mes impressions
ça ça me fait rire c'est pour ça que je
la dois je vais tout vous raconter je
vais toujours à goûter j'utilise cette
brosse à dents la visite que je tiens là
dans mamma en fait j'ai exprimé mon
haleine avant d'arriver et j'ai senti à
un moment un coup de publier plus fort
que les autres
en fait mon à l'elfe est tombé mais dans
des toiles ah bon c'est vous les dents
avec une brosse à dents comme dit ma
caisse dit mes chéris et ben voilà donc
voilà ma dernière dans est là qui est
tombé à cause de mandat n de poneys
décédé
merci pour ces conseils bac on va
maintenant prendre des nouvelles d'un
collègue animateur c'est laurent
wauquiez bonjour à tous et bon goût
c'est lille
rassurez vous moi je ne ferais pas
référence à cette histoire de molaires
oui j'aurais trop peur qu'ensuite vous
ayez une dent contre moi pardon cyril en
plus vous avez toujours été élégant avec
moi donc je tenais à vous rendre
l'appareil dentaire
non la syrie je voulais surtout vous
féliciter pour vos audiences
vous êtes le roi de l'antenne d'ailleurs
on a vu que vous auriez bien besoin
d'une couronne
salut tout le monde c'est bizarre
cyril cette histoire de dans là ça me
fait penser à une devinette qu'est ce
qu'il ya trente bras 5dans et une demi
molle pas une partout laissant place mon
client série l'as monaco il avait un
impact sur son dentier d'une taille
supérieure à une pièce de deux euros
on lui a injecté notre régime spécial
dans les gencives ça n'a pas tenu
faut dire que c'est complètement con
d'aller faire soigner ses dents chez
carglass aaa
bon je vous laisse il faut que j'avais
donné des cours de comédie à jo wilfried
tsonga pour la pub kinder bueno à la
semaine prochaine
courtois